to Hong Kong now where police have
arrested 15 high-profile democracy
campaigners in connection to the massive
protests last year the arrests include
activists lawmakers and the owner of an
anti-establishment newspaper they're
accused of either taking part in
protests or publicizing them Hong Kong
was shaken by widespread street protests
in 2019 which were sparked by a now
abandoned proposal to allow extradition
to the Chinese mainland well for more
I'm joined now by Lok in hey he's the
vice chair of the Democratic Party of
Hong Kong thank you so much for being on
our program now the founder of your
party the founder of your party Martin
Lee was in fact among those who were
arrested and we understand he said he
was proud to be arrested when he was
released on bail what do you think he
meant by that because this fight for
democracy has been 40 years all right so
you say that these arrests actually
targeted the veterans of Hong Kong's
pro-democracy movement why do you think
they were taken into custody right now
[Music]
arresting them making such a noise big
noise people from again so I think a
street and planted tatics from Beijing
to try to even to Hong Kong well do you
believe that these tactics will be
successful do you think these arrests
will end a weakening the pro-democracy
movement in Hong Kong because Hong Kong
for so many years is one of those who
trusts a basic law and he has been
defending the one country two systems'
the freedom of Hong Kong for so many
years so a lot of people to try to calm
the society so I think it's not useful
for the government to do this to try to
minimize the people out the protest it
is in culture people are more angry and
they will go out right after all right
lokan hey the vice chair of the
democratic party of hong kong thank you
very much now let's get you a quick
roundup of coronavirus developments
around the world the confirmed global
death toll has now exceeded
150,000 that's according to the Johns
Hopkins University in the United States
in Spain the official death toll has now
surpassed 20,000 people on a more
positive note South Korea has reported
only 18 new cases its lowest daily jump
in more than two months